NEARLY 11 MONTHS INTO THE WAR
IN UKRAINE, A SENIOR UKRAINIAN
OFFICIAL IN THE EAST SAYS, THE
ARMED FORCES ARE IN CONTROL OF
ITS CURRENT POSITIONS MOVING
FORWARD, IT IS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE RUSSIANS --
SUBSTANTIAL RESERVES.
UKRAINIAN FORCES HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO ADVANCE ON THE CITY
OF KREMINNA IN THE LUHANSK
REGION, IN THE HOPES OF
REGAINING THE RUSSIAN HELD
CITIES OF LYSYCHANSK, AND
SIEVIERODONETSK.
CNN'S BEN WEDEMAN REPORTS FROM
EASTERN UKRAINE ON A GROUP OF
VOLUNTEERS TRYING TO HELP
CIVILIANS NEAR THE FRONT LINES.
>> DOWN A WORLD TRADE AND PAT
--
HEADS TOWARDS HOME.
PERHAPS, FOR THE LAST TIME.
SASHA, A TRAVEL AGENT TURNED
VOLUNTEER WILL HELP WEEKEND FOR
THE JOURNEY TO KYIV, IT IS TIME
TO BE THE FAMILY.
>> I WANT TO SEE MY
GRANDCHILDREN, I HAVE FOR HE
SAYS, AND MY SON JUST GOT
DRAFTED.
>> NEIGHBORS WILL LOOK AFTER
HIS CHICKENS, GOATS, AND DOG.
THAT IS, ALL HE SAYS, LET'S GO,
GUYS, THEY START SHELLING NOW.
HE IS LEAVING WITH A GROUP OF
YOUNG UKRAINIANS TO DELIVER
FOOD AND SUPPLIES TO SOLDIERS,
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES, AND
EVACUATE THOSE --
THEY HAD CLOSE CALLS, PLENTY,
SAYS SASHA IN BAKHMUT, CLUSTER
BOMBS ARE ALL AROUND, THIS WE
DUCKED AND GOD PROTECTED US.
A YEAR AGO, --
MANAGED CAR PARTS STORE.
>> AND WHEN THE WAR STARTED
SINCE FEBRUARY 2022, WE CAME
TOGETHER AND TOOK A BUS AND
TOGETHER --
AND MAY OUR VISITS TO --
>> AND HOT THESE POINTS ARE.
THEY VENTURE THROUGH VILLAGES
STILL UNDER FIRE, RAVAGED BY
MONTHS OF SHELLING.
THEY HAVE COME TO THIS VILLAGE
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE THEY HEARD
REPORTS THAT 27 OR STILL HERE,
SO FAR, THOUGH THEY HAVE NOT
FOUND ANY.
FINALLY, THEY FIND A --
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HIDING, IN A
SHELTER.
THE VOLUNTEERS QUICKLY GET TO
WORK WITH NO TIME TO WASTE.
WE ARE ALWAYS IN THE BASEMENT
SAYS --
WE GO THERE AS SOON AS THEY
START SHELLING, ESPECIALLY IN
THE LAST DAYS, IT IS VERY HARD.
SHE OWNED A CAFÉ NEAR KYIV, BUT
LEFT IT TO BE HERE.
SHE PREFERS TO KEEP HER MOTHER
IN THE DARK.
I DON'T ALWAYS TELL WHERE I GO,
BECAUSE SHE IS WORRIED FOR MY
LIFE, SHE SAYS, I GO ANYWAY.
IN ANOTHER VILLAGE, THEY ARE
EVACUATING --
WHO IS SUFFERING FROM FROSTBITE,
OR SO HE BELIEVES, HE HAS NOT
SEEN A DOCTOR.
I WAS BUT --
NOW IT HURTS WHEN I WALK AND I
CANNOT GET ANY TREATMENT HERE,
HE SAYS, THERE ARE NO, DOCTORS
NO HOSPITALS, SO I ASKED MY
DAUGHTER TO HELP ME.
IN THE EVENING, HIS DAUGHTER --
HOSPITAL IN NEARBY --
HER RELIEF SAYS IT ALL.
BEN WEDEMAN, CNN, EASTERN
FOREIGN MINISTERS FROM THE EU
WILL MEET TO DISCUSS THE WAR IN
UKRAINE, AND THEIR SUPPORT --
AS UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS CONTINUE
TO URGE THE WEST TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE GERMAN MADE
LEOPARD TWO TANKS, WHICH POLAND
IS ALREADY ACTUALLY OFFERED UP.
AND ON SUNDAY, GERMANY'S
FOREIGN MINISTER --
WAS SO, FAR BERLIN HAS BEEN
HESITANT --
SUPPLY THANKS FROM ITS OWN
ARSENAL.
AND, GERMAN CHANCELLOR OLAF
SCHOLZ SAID ALL DECISIONS ON
WHETHER --
WOULD BE MADE IN COORDINATION
WITH ALLIES.
WE HAVE CONSTANTLY EXPANDED OUR
SUPPLY WITH VERY EFFECTIVE
WEAPONS THAT ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE TODAY, AND ALL THE
IMPORTANT ALLIES AND FRIENDS
WITH FRANCE FOR EXAMPLE WITH
USA FOR EXAMPLE, WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES IN EUROPE --
FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON SAID HIS COUNTRY HAS NOT
RULED OUT SUPPLYING ITS OWN --
BUT HE SAID THE DELIVERY MUST
NOT ESCALATE THE SITUATION, IT
SHOULD INCLUDE ENOUGH TRAINING
FOR UKRAINIANS, AND MUST NOT
WEAKEN FRANCIS OWN DEFENSE.
NOW EVEN AS UKRAINE CONTINUES
URGING ALLIES OF THE SAME HEAVY
TANKS AND MODERN EQUIPMENT, THE
FRONT LINES OF RUSSIA'S WAR
HAVE ALREADY TURNED INTO A
TESTING GROUND OF SORTS FOR
WESTERN WEAPONS.
AND TACTICS, GIVING NATIONS
AROUND THE WORLD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO STUDY OUT SYSTEMS PERFORM
UNDER REAL WORLD CONDITIONS.
>> JOINING ME NOW, THE DIRECTOR
OF THE INTERNATIONAL SECURITY
PROGRAM AND CENTER OF --
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO PUT UP --
>> IT IS A GREAT QUESTION, MIKE,
I HAVE TALKED RECENTLY WITH
SENIOR OFFICIALS AND IN THE
PACIFIC, WITH COUNTRIES LIKE
AUSTRALIA, JAPAN, AND WHAT THEY
HAVE REPEATEDLY TOLD ME, IT IS
A CASE STUDY FOR HOW TO CONDUCT
AN INDUSTRIAL STYLE WAR, SO
THEY LOOKED AT DRONES, THEY
LOOKED AT HOW TO DO LOGISTICS,
YOU SQUARE, PARTS SPARE AMINO,
SHUNS OR PETROLEUM, LUBRICANTS,
INTO THE VEHICLES AND CONTESTED
ENVIRONMENT, THEY LOOKED AT
LONG RANGE FIRES AND THE NEED
FOR POSITION MUNITIONS, SO
INTERESTING TALKING TO SENIOR
OFFICIALS AROUND TAIWAN AS WELL,
IT IS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
SCENARIO, DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC
AREA, BUT HUGE LOSSES THERE IN
ALL THESE ISSUES.
>> YEAH, AND WITHOUT GETTING
INTO THE --
WHAT WEAPONS HAVE STOOD OUT AS
A BIG, AND PERHAPS SURPRISING
SUCCESS, AND WHAT PERHAPS
HAVEN'T PERFORMED AS WELL AS
SOME HAVE EXPECTED?
>> WELL I THINK THERE ARE TWO
TYPES ON THE SURPRISING SIDE,
ONE FOR ME HAS BEEN AIR DEFENSE.
AFTER WATCHING THE RUSSIANS
PERFORM ADMIRABLY IN SYRIA, THE
UKRAINIAN --
THE STINGERS, THE NAYS, AND THE
HAWKS, THEY HAVE MADE IT
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
RUSSIAN FIRE CRAFT IN UKRAINE
WHICH IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
DIFFICULT SITUATION FOR THEM.
THE OTHER, WHICH WE GET INTO
MORE DETAIL AS, WELL IS THE
DRONES.
AND, NOT JUST FOR, STRIKE OR
INTELLIGENCE COLLECTION, BUT
ALSO FOR INFORMATION OPERATIONS,
ELECTRONIC WARFARE, TARGETING
FOR OTHER SYSTEMS TO CONDUCT
STRIKES, WHAT WE CALL COMBINED
ARMS, AND THEN ALL STUFF THAT
HAS NOT WORKED WELL, CYBER, WE
EXPECTED THE RUSSIANS TO BE
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE ON THE
CYBER SIDE, THEY HAVE NOT BEEN.
>> YEAH, AND, IT IS INTERESTING
WITH, DRONES AS THEY SAY, THEY
ARE BEING USED IN AN OFFENSIVE
WAY, AND OBSERVATIONAL, WAY BUT
ALSO WE'VE SEEN ALL THOSE
VIDEOS OF GRENADES BEING
DROPPED LITERALLY ON TOP OF
RUSSIANS IN THEIR BUNKERS BY
DRONES, I GUESS IT IS NOT JUST
WEAPONS PERFORMANCE ON DISPLAY,
BUT TACTICS AS WELL.
--
CERTAINLY ONE EXAMPLE, UKRAINE
TRUST COMMANDOES DOWN THE CHAIN
OR THE GROUND TO MAKE DECISIONS
AND ACT INDEPENDENTLY, THE
RUSSIANS DO NOT.
>> RIGHT, ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HAVE SEEN IS MUCH LIKE THE U.S.
MILITARY WHICH HAS NON
COMMISSIONED OFFICERS,
UKRAINIANS AND MANY OF THEIR
UNITS DO.
THE RUSSIANS DO NOT.
AND, ONE OF THE CHALLENGES FOR
THE RUSSIANS IS THAT WE DO NOT
SEE AS MUCH INITIATIVE AT LOWER
LEVELS OF THE RUSSIAN MILITARY,
WHICH IS MEANT THAT WE HAVE
SEEN GENERALS HAVING TO MOVE
CLOSELY TO THE FRONT LINES AND
WE'VE SEEN LARGE NUMBERS OF
THOSE GENERAL OFFICERS KILLED
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO
COMMAND SO CLOSE TO THE FRONT
LINES, SO THOSE NON
COMMISSIONED OFFICERS AND LACK
OF INITIATIVE WE'VE SEEN, LACK
OF NON-COMMISSION OFFICERS,
LACK OF INITIATIVE FROM THE
RUSSIANS AS BEEN A REAL
DEBILITATING PART OF THEIR
INEFFECTIVENESS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
>> YEAH, AND ALSO, I GUESS
UKRAINE'S --
USE OF DISMOUNTED INFANTRY AS
WELL WHICH HAD THE RUSSIANS
OFF-GUARD EARLY ON.
I GUESS TO THE POINT YOUR,
MAKING RUSSIA'S MILITARY WAS BY
AND LARGE ALWAYS TAKING
SERIOUSLY UNTIL THIS WAR,
FEARED BY MANY, BUT AS THE WAR
SORT OF LAID BARE ITS WEAK SPOT
AND FEELINGS?
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN,
UKRAINE THE GOVERNMENT SAID
RUSSIA IS NOT ONLY THE SECOND
BEST ARMY IN THE WORLD, THEY
ARE NOT THE SECOND BEST IN
UKRAINE.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT IS
INTERESTING, MICHAEL, I HAVE
TALKED TO SENIOR INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS FROM THE UNITED
STATES, FROM THE UK, FROM
AUSTRALIA AMONG OTHERS, ALL OF
WHOSE AGENCIES GENERALLY
ASSESSED THE RUSSIANS HAD
PRETTY GOOD CAPABILITIES,
ARTILLERY, AIRCRAFT, AIR RANGE
MISSILES, AND THEY HAD
REASONABLE DOCTRINE TO FIGHT
THE WAR LIKE THIS.
BUT THE CHALLENGE WE SEE IT IS
HARD TO TRANSITION TO THE
QUALITATIVE PARTS, THE ARE NOT
AS EASY TO MEASURE, GROUND,
FORCES COMMANDING CONTROL,
INITIATIVE, READINESS, THEY'RE
WILLING TO FIGHT IN COMBINED
ARMS, AND THERE WAS A LOT OF US
STATEMENT OF HOW THE RUSSIANS
WERE TRANSLATE THEIR
CAPABILITIES INTO ACTIONS ON
THE GROUND, AND AT THE SAME
TIME AND UNDER APPRECIATION FOR
UKRAINIAN ARMY THAT WAS MUCH
LESS WELL EQUIPPED BUT HOW THEY
WERE ACTUALLY BETTER ON THOSE
COMPONENTS.
>> YEAH, IT IS A FASCINATING
SUBJECT, AND GREAT THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO TAP AND YOUR EXPERTISE.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MICHAEL.